so I think the the best place to actually start is I was actually one of
those people who became Muslim like on my own
literally 20 years ago um on New Year's Eve
I after looking at Islam and studying and reflecting actually on it for a many years
at least three years I like finally took that leap to like make the sh
to actually
say
and I did that all alone in my room
and for at least four or five months I actually really just had that experience of
being alone
um I knew why I chose to be Muslim I had no doubts in I see
doing it
but there was definitely something clearly missing
and I would actually make it analogous to
um actually track
so if you ever been to a track meet before you actually look and you'll see
that in the track meet there's so many things actually going on at any given time
there's a lot of events going on
and actually there'll be the idea of a team that's one team versus another team versus
another team right
but if you really look at it
there's a lot of individual successes and failures just really going on there somebody can actually
their team might be able to win the event
but there could be somebody who played a lot better in one particular particular part part
of sport whether that be shot put whether that be how they jumped whether be how
they ran
so in a way it's like there's there could be a lot of chaos when you
actually look at the sport and there's a lot of like aloneness and so that's what
I was I was like a Muslim almost like got attract me I was very much
alone in my experience and I didn't actually have the sense of community and the biggest
piece of actually a shift for me where life actually became different was when I actually
finally went to the mosque
and believe it or not it was because somebody who I was friends with and I
didn't even know he was Muslim at the time he said he had gone to this
particular mosque so actually took the trk and walked to this mosque and after walking to
this mosque and actually after having just so many years of wanting to become Muslim want
to actually really know am I really a Muslim do I like really belong I actually
had to sit down with somebody in the mosque and actually even wasn't like an Imam
or some big figure it was actually just somebody who was at the mosque at the
time
who um was a professional he just sat down with me and he answered all my
questions I was asking him some basic questions about em man about belief and in that
one moment in that 40 minutes or 20 minutes that that man gave me in that
conversation I actually just felt like this sense
of of Peace really come come over me and a sense of yeah almost like a
sense of belonging and from then on it's like I got introduced to his children and
actually started going to the mosque
and then I really started getting a sense of actually that aspect of the peace that
actually was in
Islam
because without that aspect of the community without that aspect of actually being actually in
in that group you never really get to experience the real flow and the part that
was so interesting is I had spent so much time reading books about how to pray
about how to practice the five pillars of Islam and it was like within five or
10 minutes being able to watch what some other people were doing
being able to be around other people being able to have a conversation about what other
people were doing I was able to get a a a higher level and a higher
sense of the dean in such a short period of time and that to me actually
speaks to the power of companionship the power of actually being able to be around somebody
else and the impact that actually has it's it's even a concept or an idea even
in the social sciences that it's not just like one person plus one person just equals
to
but actually the group actually as you add each person it has its own Spirit it
has its own flavor just if you even think about movements when people actually came together
whether I mean to like uh for empowerment of of African-American
like when people come together there's a spirit that actually comes over the group there's a
spirit that actually comes all of its own that's not just 1 plus one plus one
plus one but it's actually a group actually has a spirit of its own and to
me that's actually one of the key aspects of Islam a key aspects of peace and
that's why it's so powerful and important to actually just be in the group and be
able to actually have companionship in Islam to actually come through some levels it's often been
said like you know you look and you'll say okay I'm here how is it that
I actually can get to another place
and the idea in Islam is very much like the idea in any other place like
if you want to be a successful businessman you start hanging out with who successful businessman
right so it's almost like the same idea as you want to learn and grow in
in your Islam how do you do that you actually spend your time around and inside
the community and I would say that that actually is is a central piece
to the other part that I actually really want to talk about which is the importance
of knowledge of Islam like so I feel like there's a place
where
um
a person actually is not going to experience the other level of Islam
um which actually has to do with peace as well if they actually don't have knowledge
like anybody if you've ever cooked something if you've ever like went through the procedure of
something knowing actually how to do it yourself gives you a sense of security gives you
a sense of confidence that that nothing else like really can
no matter how well you actually might follow something no matter how well that you actually
might like look at somebody and go right behind them there's a different sense that you
actually have when you know what's about to come next even if you're following when you
when you actually know okay so this person turns this way I know I know like
because of my own GPS for example if I'm actually following somebody and I have my
own GPS I still have a security okay I know this is the route that's supposed
to go and that's actually in a sense the power of actually learning and studying in
the religion the idea of you actually ever belonging or you actually feeling like this Dean
is is
is like this big elepant
and like being afraid to actually or not knowing if you actually really belong that experience
is never really going to go away unless you actually really start taking some steps to
really start to know
what it is that that God is actually asking in particular of you what it is
that God is actually asking in particular of the community because there's different levels of things
that a person is actually asked to do and and that will again come about when
you actually seek it out and Company so actually as you spend time in the community
you start knowing actually who is the more knowledgeable person who is the type of person
that you actually want to Aspire to and that in of itself will un fold the
type of people that you really want to be around amongst the groups of Muslims that
actually are there that actually will help guide you to being more secure in yourself and
having that sense of Peace about your religion and so in that same vein it really
talks about the importance of the conversation that's going to take on take place on April
17th at Ruckus University it's an opportunity to actually come together as Muslims
and be able to taste from the number of convers that are actually out there and
be able to have a conversation about some of the concerns that exist some of the
things that we struggle with as we actually go through our Islam and be able for
you to find
that group that individual maybe even just one person make the network network with one person
that's going to have it so that your Islam can go from where it is and
be able to build and go along to a place where you get a higher sense
of Peace because that's just really what I believe the heart of this religion is really
about